اسمي تشارلز جوردون
الآن أنا [ __ ] أمريكي واحد من بين 20
مليونًا أريد أن أريكم شيئًا من حياتنا
هنا أعتقد
أنه شيء مثير للسخرية أن تأخذ
الناس البيض في الجنوب الذين
ليسوا فقط في الجنوب في أي مكان
يرفض  للسماح
لرجل [ __ ] أو امرأة زنجية بالجلوس
في مطعم أو الركوب
بجانبهم في حافلة أو قطار أو
أي شيء
ثم استدر من ناحية أخرى
وتريد
أن تأتي امرأة ملونة إلى منزلهم وتطبخ
طعامهم و  قدم
لهم العشاء بعد وضع أيدينا كلها
في طعامهم ،
أعتقد أن شخصًا ما يجب أن يكون
مجنونًا.  لا أعلم أنك لست مضطرًا للعيش بجواري
فقط أعطني صفاتي
والجميع يعلم الجميع
أن هذا
المساء جيد بغض النظر عن
وجهة نظرك قد يكون
هناك أهمية في النمو في
شيكاغو وعبر الولايات المتحدة
وليس حول  عالم الحركة المعروف
نظرًا لأن حركة المسلمين السود
التي يُعتقد عمومًا أنها
تبشر بعقيدة الكراهية
للعرق الأبيض ،
فإن السيادة المطلقة لمقر قيادة عرق الزنوج ،
فإن الحركة الإسلامية موجودة هنا
في شيكاغو في كتلة 5300 من جنوب
جرين وود
ويعرف زعيمها الآن باسم إيليا
محمد  إنه يقيم
هنا ، أكثر الأشخاص نشاطا في
انتشار الحركة الإسلامية السوداء هو إيليا
محمد الثاني في الأمر ،
ويدعو نفسه مالكولم x ،
لقد ولدت في أوماها ، هذا صحيح ، نعم
سيدي وتركت عائلتك
أوماها عندما كان عمرك حوالي سنة.
تخيلت حوالي عام الآن لماذا
تركوا أوماها جيدًا
لفهمي أه أحرقوا
أحد منازلهم في أه
في أه في أوماها ، هناك الكثير من الأشخاص الذين
جعلوا عائلتك تشعر بالتعاسة الشديد
أنا متأكد
غير آمن جيدًا إن لم يكن غير سعيد ،
كانت والدته هي
سكرتيرة التسجيل الوطنية لحركة ماركوس غارفي ،
كان والده رئيس فرع الغرب الأوسط
لهذه المنظمة
ومتى  تم إعدام والديه بدون محاكمة ،
تم إعدام والده ، تم إرسال والدته
إلى مؤسسة
وقاموا بفصل الأطفال
من أجل فهم كيف يشعر أي [ __ ]
تحت الفصل العنصري عليك أن
تدرك أنه
منذ وقت الطفولة قام
بضربه عليه بأنه  ليس جيدًا
مثل الآخرين ،
هناك أشياء لا يستطيع القيام بها ، لا
يمكنك فعل ذلك ، لا يمكنك فعل ذلك ، لا يمكنك فعل
الآخر ،
فهو يبني على الرجل شعورًا
بالنقص ، شعورًا بالإحباط
، شعورًا بالاستياء
والدي  كان في الجزء العلوي من
فصله وحتى عندما سأله معلمه المفضل
عما يريد أن يكون لم
يقل أنني أريد أن
أصبح لاعب بيسبول أو موسيقيًا أو
طبيبًا ، قال أنني أريد أن أصبح محاميًا وأساعد
أولئك الذين لا يستطيعون  التحدث عن أنفسهم
والدفاع عن أولئك الذين لا يستطيعون الدفاع عن
أنفسهم والذين يحتاجون
إليها وعندما قال معلمه
المفضل أن هذا ليس هدفًا واقعيًا
لأنك لا تعرف
أنك [ __ ] ولا يستطيع الزنوج استخدام
عقولهم.  استخدم
فقط  أيديهم كانت تسحق
الفصل العنصري إلى الزنجي العادي مما يعني
أنه يبحث عن التقدم الذي يريد
المضي قدمًا
في الفصل العنصري السائد في أمريكا يعيقه
[موسيقى]
ثم بدأ والدي في اتخاذ
قرارات مختلفة
لنفسه وانقطع عن المدرسة وانتقل  إلى
بوسطن وكان منبهراً بكل
المباني والسيارات والأشخاص الذين
تعرفهم بالموسيقى ،
فقد بدأ في الذهاب إلى النوادي الليلية
والحصول على وظائف هناك
وبدأ تعرف
بالمخدرات التي تعرف أن السجائر
تشرب الكحول وكونك
شابًا ولكن يبحث  أكبر سنًا ، أنت تعلم أنني كنت أعيش
حياة سريعة
كنت
حقًا في حالة سيئة ، لكن ما هو نوع الحالة
السيئة التي كنت في حالة
جيدة ، كنت زنجيًا نموذجيًا ، لقد كنت في حالة سكر ، لقد
عشت في الملاهي الليلية.
معظم
إدمان المنشطات هو أكثر دعارة
وجنوح الأحداث
وهذه لعنة في مجتمعنا
الخاص وكنت جزءًا من ذلك في
السيرة الذاتية h  يتحدث عن
جرائم أكثر خطورة من تلك التي تشمل
السطو الذي تم القبض عليه من أجله أخيرًا ،
كنت مجرمًا ضالًا جدًا متخلفًا
وأميًا وغير متعلم وأيًا كانت
الخصائص السلبية الأخرى أه يمكنك
التفكير في
نوع الشخص حتى سمعت
تعاليم الشرف إيليا
محمد.
قال الرجل الأبيض مع كونه
أعظم كاذب
على وجه الأرض ، إيليا محمد ،
أنه تعلم من
خلال قانون مباشر
أن الله قد أعلن أن إيليا
محمد آخر نبي
له يخرج من السجن ويلتقي بإيليا
محمد وبدأ يقرأ فوجد الإسلام كان كذلك.
لقد كان شكلاً من أشكال الإسلام لن تدرك أنك لن
تعترف
بالحرية
[موسيقى]
استخدم التعبير الأمريكي خارج العلامة التجارية
مجموعة من المعارضين الزنوج ينتقلون إلى
سلالم زاوية الشارع منابر الكنيسة
الساحات الرياضية ومنصات القاعات
عبر الولايات المتحدة  تنص
على التبشير بإنجيل الكراهية ولاحظت
أنه بعد
التعرض للتعاليم
الدينية للشرفاء  ijah Mohammed على
الفور غرس في داخلي درجة عالية
من
الفخر العنصري والكرامة العرقية لدرجة أنني أردت أن أكون
شخصًا وأدركت أنه لا يمكنني أن
أكون أي شخص بالتوسل
للرجل الأبيض لما كان لديه ولكن
كان علي الخروج من هنا  وأحاول أن أفعل
شيئًا لنفسي
أو أصنع شيئًا من نفسي ولكن
الأمر الأكثر أهمية بالنسبة
لنيويورك هو مالكولم x وزير المسلمين في نيويورك
الذي أخبر نيوزبيت أن حياته تغيرت
بالنسبة له عندما علمه الدين الإسلامي أنه
لم يعد يخجل منه.  نظرًا لكوننا رجلًا أسود ،
فقد جئنا لنسمع ونرى
الرجل الأسود الأعظم والأكثر حكمة والأكثر
شجاعة في أمريكا اليوم ،
بحلول ذلك الوقت ،
أصبح الصوت
الرئيسي لأمة الإسلام ، وكان
لديهم أساطيرهم الخاصة  أن
هناك طائرة أم عظيمة في
السماء تمطر نيرانًا على
البيض خارج قاعة المحكمة ،
سألت مالكولم إكس في أول
مقابلة تلفزيونية له
ما إذا كان النبي المسلم الأسود
يدعو إلى الكراهية العرقية
إنه لا يعلم الكراهية ، إنه يعلمك
التاريخ الذي علمك أن تكره
شكل أنفك
وشكل شفتيك الذي
علمك أن تدفئ نفسك
من أعلى رأسك إلى
أخمص قدميك
الذي علمك أن تكره نوعك الذي
علمك أن تكره العرق
الذي تنتمي إليه كثيرًا بحيث
لا تريد أن تكون حول بعضكما البعض ،
لا قبل أن تسأل السيد محمد
هل يعلمه ،
يجب أن تسأل نفسك من الذي علمك
أن تكره أن تكون ما أعطاك إياه الله
[  تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
عندما جاء مالكولم إلى أمة
الإسلام ، كان
بإمكانك وضع كل أتباعه
في عربة المحطة
ولا يزال لديك بعض المساحة المتبقية ، لكن
مالكولم
جاء وذهب للعمل كما تعلم
لم
يكن من المفترض أبدًا أن تقوم أمة الإسلام  تنمو بالطريقة
التي فعلت بها
ولكن مالكولم أخذها من الأزقة الخلفية
وأدخلها إلى الجامعات في
جميع أنحاء هذا البلد
، فعل كل شيء وقام بتحويل منظمة صغيرة
إلى شيء كبير حقًا
ومزدهر ،
نحن لا نطلب منك ذلك
أعطونا المال لنجعلنا أغنياء ، لقد أنشأنا أعمالًا
على الطريق ، أنشأ إيليا محمد أعمالًا أكثر
من أي رجل أسود في أمريكا.
تم إنشاؤها بواسطة عالم مجنون
في جزيرة باتموس
شياطين العين الزرقاء ولدي عيون زرقاء
نقلت عنك عندما
تحطمت طائرة ركاب على متنها عدد من الأشخاص البيض
ولكنك كنت سعيدًا لحدوث
العرق الأبيض في هذا البلد
مجتمعين مذنبون بهذه الجرائم التي
يعاني منها شعبنا
أه بشكل جماعي وبالتالي
سيعانون من كارثة
جماعية حزن جماعي
وعندما تحطمت تلك الطائرة في فرنسا
وعليها 130
أبيض وعلمنا أن 120 منهم كانوا
من دولة
جورجيا حالة أجدادي كانوا
عبيدًا
لماذا بالنسبة لي لم يكن الأمر
سوى عمل من
الله نعمة من الله وأنا بصراحة
وإخلاص
صلي من أجل الحصول على بركات مماثلة منه
لتكرار ما قاله كثيرًا بقدر ما يستطيع أن
يجنيها حتى يسهل على أصدقائي القول بأن
وحدتنا ستمنح الرجل الأبيض الجحيم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لذا في عام 1964
بدأ والدي  تعلم أن الانتظار لمدة
دقيقة ،
قد لا يكون هذا هو الإسلام الحقيقي
[موسيقى] ،
فقد قام به في أواخر ربيع
عام 1964.
أعتقد أنه كان لديه دافع ديني عميق حقيقي
للذهاب
عندما قام بالحج
والذهاب إلى هذا المكان الذي بدأت فيه الحضارة
ولرؤية كل هذا التاريخ والدين
، فمن الصحيح تمامًا أنه يختلف
عما كان عليه في أمريكا أن ما
تم تلقينه لمئات
السنين
[موسيقى] كان
يرتدي الجميع
ملابس الهودج
البيضاء ، ولم يكن هناك أي بياض أو أعلى
السود أو أقل شأناً من
ذلك كان نوعًا من الدمقرطة المثالية ،
لقد كانت تجربة روحية أكثر عمقًا
ورأى أن الأشخاص البيض
هنا
أشقر الشعر والعيون الزرقاء البياض
الذي كنا فيه  يعتقد أنه
كان عرقًا ولكن ليس في أمريكا
أن هذا الإحساس بالتفوق
والقمع لم يكن
موجودًا وكان هناك شعور بالأخوة والأخوة
على أساس كونهم مسلمين فقط
أعتقد أن الدعوة تم ترتيبها
بمساعدة السعودية  الحكومة
كان يريدها بشدة ،
لكنني كنت محظوظًا لأنني كنت
معروفًا جيدًا من قبل المسؤولين في المملكة
العربية السعودية
وأصبحت ضيفًا على الدولة
كنت ضيفًا
على الأمير فيصل الملك الحالي فيصل الذي
فكرت فيه في حياة والدي
هو  لم يسبق له أن واجه أي شيء من
هذا القبيل وكان
يُعامل كرجل هنا ، إنه في
بلد
يكافح من أجل حقوق الإنسان ، فقط الحق في
أن يكون
حقًا من حقوق الإنسان ويسافر إلى الخارج
ويعامله العديد من الشخصيات المرموقة على أنه رجل
مرموق ، ولذا يجب أن يعود
وقول انظروا إلى
هذا الدين العظيم الذي تعلم أنه
يبشر
بالسلام الذي يبشر بالأخوة والأخوة ،
فأنت تعلم أنه ليس شيئًا كما كنا
نتعلمه هنا ،
لذا فإن
دينه إيمانه  تعمق الإيمان
في آرائه السياسية
واتسعت وتعمقت
[موسيقى] ،
لذلك عندما أقام الحج ،
تعلمون أنه قرر للتو
أنه لن يكون مع تلك المنظمة
[الموسيقية] ،
يعتقد معظم المسلمين الذين يتبعون السيد محمد تمامًا أن الأمر كذلك
مستحيل ماديًا ، يجب أن أقول أنه من
المستحيل إلهيًا
أن يذهب شخص أبيض إلى مكة
أه ورحلتي هناك أه حطمت تلك
الصورة
أو أن هذا المفهوم
ثم انفجرت التوترات داخل أمة الإسلام
لولا
الانغماس الروحي له.  ما كانت الآراء السياسية
لتتغير إلى الدرجة التي لم تكن قد تغيرت فيها
الليلة التي يرحب بها تحدي الصفحة الأولى
بالزعيم الزنجي الصريح
مالكولم إكس ، فأنا لا أؤمن بأي شكل من أشكال
الفصل العنصري
أو أي شكل من أشكال العنصرية ، فأنا ضد أي
شكل من أشكال الفصل وضد  العنصرية
أنه لن
يتخلى عن آرائه السياسية
كان سيتخلى عن كل الشيطان الأبيض
المنشق العلماء يخلق أشخاصًا بيضًا
كان ذاهبًا إليه  الابتعاد عن
ذلك على الرغم من أننا لسنا
اندماجًا ونعتقد أنك أحمق
لمحاولة الاختلاط مع شخص لا يحبك ،
لكن هذا تغيير كبير في
الرأي في مالكولم إكس
لا اليوم أنا أتحدث عن نفسي
سابقًا  تحدثت عن إيليا محمد
وكل ما قلته هو أن إيليا
محمد يعلمنا
هكذا وهكذا فأنا أتحدث الآن مما
أفكر فيه
مما رأيته مما قمت بتحليله
والاستنتاجات التي قرأتها
ثم لم يعد الرجل الأبيض هو
شيطان ولم يعد
ملزمًا بأن يكون شريرًا إذا حكمت على الرجل من خلال
سلوكه الواعي ، فأنا لست عنصريًا ،
فأنا لا أؤيد أيًا من
مبادئ العنصرية ، فهناك
بياض جيدون وسود جيدون وأبيض وسود سيئون
.  ليست حالة جيدة وسيئة
جيدة أو سوداء وبيضاء سيئة ، إنها
حالة إنسان طيب أو
سيئ ،
وكان يعتقد أنه إذا
درس الأمريكيون
الإسلام ودرسوا وحدانية الله ،
فسيكون
هناك المزيد من
فهم  شقيق نقي  د والأخت
وليس أنت تعرف
أهوال وصدمات العنصرية هذه ،
فأنت تعلم أنه ربما يمكننا حقًا أن
نؤمن بوحدانية الله
بغض النظر عما
إذا كنت تعلم إذا كنت تسمي نفسك
مسيحيًا ، فأنت تسمي نفسك يهوديًا
تسمي نفسك مسلمًا ، فأنت تسمي
نفسك مهما كان
صحيحًا  البوذي اللاأدري أنه
إذا مارسنا الإسلام إذا
مارسنا وحدانية الله ، فيمكننا
القضاء على هذا الشيء الذي يسمح
للمرء بإبادة
شخص ما بسبب
الدونية التي يتم توقعها على
أن إيليا محمد كان لديه الكثير من
الأمناء الشباب الجميلين الذين
اقتبسوا أقتبس الآن أنا '  اكتشف أن
هناك أشياء يشارك فيها الشخص الرئيسي
أو ينخرط فيها ، وبالتالي
تم إخراجه في النهاية من
المنظمة
ثم تم تعليقه من
المنظمة وتم تعليقه من
جميع الأنشطة العامة ، حيث
بدأت تهديدات على حياته
من  أمة الإسلام لماذا
يهددون حياتك
بشكل جيد أه بالدرجة الأولى لأنهم خائفون من
أن أتصل  السبب الحقيقي في
أنهم كانوا خارج المرأة السوداء
وهو ما لم أخبره أبدًا أنني احتفظت بنفسي
ولكن السبب الحقيقي هو أن إيليا
محمد رئيس الحركة
هو أب لثمانية أطفال من قبل ستة
مراهقين مختلفين
الفتاة التي كانت آخر مرة
أجريت فيها مقابلة معه ، في الواقع
، كان ذلك بعد ظهر اليوم الذي
انفصل عنه ، اتصل بمؤتمر صحفي
للإعلان عن
الاستراحة والتقيت به بعد ظهر ذلك اليوم
مرة أخرى لبضع ساعات
وكانت
تلك هي المرة الأخيرة التالية  رأيت
[تصفيق]
الإخوة
[الموسيقى]
كانوا عائلتك في السرير في
وقت التعرض لهذا الصباح ، لا يمكنني حقًا أن
أقول
ما حدث بالضبط ، ولا أعرف ما إذا كنت
أمشي فوق زوجي ، فقد أيقظني
ولكني أتذكره  دفعني للخروج من
باب غرفة النوم ونظرت إلى
يميني ورأيت كل النيران قبل أسبوع من
يوم عيد الحب ، وقد
تم
إلقاء قنبلة حارقة على منزلنا ، ألقيت قنبلة حارقة في منزل
مالكولم إكس هنا في مدينة نيويورك في وقت مبكر من
هذا الصباح  تعرض منزل
لأضرار جسيمة ث  إيث مالكولم × زوجته
وأطفاله الأربعة لم يصابوا بجروح ،
أردت أن تعرف أن منزلي
تعرض للقصف من قبل
الحركة الإسلامية السوداء بناء على
أوامر من إيليا محمد
، هل كان لديك أي تهديدات أه أي شيء مثل
هذا في الخيوط التي
أنا  أحصل على خيوطه التي تصلني أه ما لا يقل عن
ستة أو سبعة
مكالمات هاتفية تهدد كل يوم
لم يرغب أصدقاؤه في إفريقيا
في عودته إلى الدول التي كانوا يعلمون أن
حياته كانت في خطر وكانوا يعرفون من كان
في خطر
من تجربتهم  للتحدث معه في دولة
لإحضار عائلته إلى إفريقيا والبقاء
في غانا ،
ولم يشعر أنه مضطر للعودة إلى
الكفاح ،
فقد عاد وكانت هناك
محاولات متكررة لاغتياله ، حيث
تعرض منزله للقصف من قبل أفراد
من الأمة.  الإسلام
[تصفيق]
يمكنني أن أتخيل أنها كانت بالتأكيد
دعوة للاستيقاظ أشعر بالمسؤولية
عن لعب دور رئيسي في
تطوير منظمة إجرامية
أعطتها القوة المعنوية
للمؤمن التي من شأنها أن تمكن  عليه أن
يسمو فوق
كل ميوله السلبية التي أعرفها
لأنني دخلت في الحركة
بميول سلبية أكثر من أي شخص آخر في
الحركة
، الشيء الوحيد الذي يؤسفني
في كل هذا هو أن مجموعتين سوداوين
عليهما القتال وقتل بعضهما البعض من
إيليا محمد.  يمكن أن يوقف الأمر برمته
غدًا
فقط برفع يده حقًا
يمكنه إيقاف الأمر برمته
برفع يده لكنه
لن يحب السود
حتى أنه لا يحب
أتباعه الذين هم منهم  قتلوا بعضهم البعض
قتلوا واحدًا في البني ، أطلقوا النار على
واحد آخر في البني
، حاولوا الحصول على ستة منا أه صباح الأحد
وأه النمط قد تطور في جميع
أنحاء البلاد ، لقد فقد الرجل
عقله تمامًا إلى جانب أنك
لا تستطيع  أن
تبلغ من العمر 70 عامًا وتحيط نفسك
بحفنة من 16 17 فتاة تبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا
واحتفظ بعقلك الصحيح
[تصفيق]
بعد أسبوع واحد قُتل والدي
بالرصاص هنا في هذا
المكان
وفي الحقيقة هناك السلام
alaikum
كنت جالسًا في الصف الأول عندما
صعد مالكولم على خشبة المسرح
ورحب بالجمهور ،
حيث حدث العديد من الأشخاص بسرعة ، ولا يمكنني
وصفهم بالضرب وأطلقوا
طلقات فريق ما أطلقوا عليه فرقة خاصة
من أعضاء أمة الإسلام من جديد.
جاء جيرسي إلى أحد اجتماعاته
وقتله وزحف مرة أخرى على طول
الميزان بشكل مستقيم وتوقف عن
الركض في كل مكان حيث حاول أنصار مالكولم
إخضاع أولئك الذين أطلقوا النار
عليه وهو الآن يرقد على المنصة
يخبرني وكيل أعمالي أنه فعل ذلك  تم إطلاق النار عليه
مرتين وأنه لا يزال على قيد الحياة مع
الناس
بعد إطلاق النار عليه ، قالوا إن الأمر
استغرق وقتًا
طويلاً حتى يستجيب أي شخص.
الشارع
بجسده
وبعد ذلك تعلم أنه تم نطقه ،
تعلمون أنهم أعلنوا أنه
لم يعد يعيش ،
وأعتقد أن الكثير في ذلك الوقت اعتقدت أننا
فقدنا
شخصية ثمينة في  حياة أمريكية
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لقد مرت فترة طويلة على
[موسيقى]
قادمة
لكنني أعلم أن
التغيير سيحدث ،
نعم ، إنه سيحدث
[موسيقى]
لقد كان شابًا في العشرينات من
عمره فقط عندما علم العالم به
كان يبلغ من العمر 39 عامًا عندما تم إطلاق النار عليه هنا
ومن كان هذا الشخص الذي أحدث
هذا التأثير العميق في
جميع أنحاء العالم من كان
[موسيقى]
هو إنسان ، لقد كان
إنسانًا والبشر معقدون وأنا
حاولت التعامل مع ذلك ،
أعتقد أنه يمكنني أن أحبه حقًا ،
لذلك هناك شيء يجذبك
إلى هذا الرجل
الذي تعرف أن هناك شيئًا عنه
تعرف أنه يمكنك الوثوق
به ، ترى صدقه ترى أنه
أنت تعرف أنك ترى من هو
هو وأنت تثق به السيد x ، هل لي أن أشكرك جزيل الشكر
على مشاركتك في برنامجنا
وربما التخلص من بعض
خيوط العنكبوت من المفاهيم الخاطئة التي
ربما كان لدى البعض منا حول إيمانك
وأعتقد أنك
رجل مخلص للغاية وهذا  يتطلب الكثير من
الشجاعة لإعلانه  معتقد سابق
خاطئ ونحن نهنئك
على ذلك وعلى الخدمة التي قدمتها
الليلة وتعطينا
آرائك شكرًا جزيلاً لك
شكرًا جزيلاً لك إنه إصراره
تمامًا على أننا سنقتله أنا
مساعد رائع
20  منذ سنوات ، أصبح رمزًا في صراع
[الموسيقى]
جيل الشباب من البيض ، السود ، البني ،
أيًا كان
ما تعيشه في زمن التطرف ،
وقت
الثورة ، وقت كان يجب أن يكون هناك تغيير
أساء فيه الناس في السلطة
وأنا شخصيا سأشارك مع أي شخص
لا يهمه لونك
طالما أنك تريد تغيير هذه
الحالة البائسة الموجودة على هذه
الأرض
، فلا يهم من أين
أنت في العالم ، فقد تكون من أوروبا
ساحل العاج الصين وأفريقيا مالي
أه الرياض يمكن أن تكون من أي مكان
في العالم طالما أنك تتعلم
حقيقة التاريخ
لذلك لأن هذا يعني أننا
لن نميز ضد الآخرين ،
فهذا لا يمنحنا الحق في  قتل
وقصف
و  وإرهاب الناس لأنهم
ليسوا
من أعتقد أنهم يجب أن يكونوا على
حق لأننا قدمنا جميعًا مس
همة كبيرة للعالم وإذا عل
نا الحقيقة ، فس
حصل على الحقيقة وا
عدالة والسلام وكل هذه ال
شياء المهمة  كان مالكولم المتعايش مع
[موسيقى]
شخصية جذابة للغاية لديه ابتسامة قاتلة
إذا ابتسمها فقط كانت دافئة
للغرفة
على الرغم من
أننا كنا أعداء اسميًا
[تصفيق]
كيف أشعر
أنني أحب والدي كثيرًا وأنا
ممتن جدًا لمثاله في الحياة.
قم بعمل يوميات ذات عيون زرقاء بيضاء
[موسيقى
] آمل أن يكون هناك أي شيء مفيد هناك
من الحرية
فوقي وقبل أن أكون عبدًا ،
سأدفن في
ذهني وأعود إلى المنزل إلى
سيدي وأكون حراً
[موسيقى]
أنا
و  كن حرا
سيكونون منغوليا  نانوغرام
سوف يغنون
هناك سيكون الغناء